he started work at 16 and you started
work in finance a very male-dominated
area still for this day how did you
forge your way ahead in your career it
was slightly different in terms of my
socioeconomic background didn't have the
academic records so it was slightly
harder for me to get a job but I did
eventually get a job in finance but it
took I think the people taking a bit of
a risk on me because on paper I wasn't
what they naturally would have taken in
terms of women getting into the area
that you specialize in so city finance
big companies and if we could take it in
baby steps because we talked about the
balancing acts that is the theme and
getting the balance right for women what
would be the next baby step the next
thing you want to see achieved in that
sector to help women more it goes back
to the sponsoring for me it's about
giving women the opportunities that they
haven't been necessarily been privy to
over the last few years which is why we
have this shortage of women at senior
levels so I think for me it would be how
can we look at our organizations see
where there are pockets of women are why
women leaving you know in particular
areas and giving them the support that
they need I mean we've done a lot in
that space around you know introducing
things like flexible working which isn't
just a women's issue if you give
flexible working to the men you help
women out anyway we've done things
around pay gap you know making sure that
pay gap reporting is transparent so the
work the city world is moved quite
quickly but I still think that sometimes
women don't have a voice at the table
it's interesting you talk about people
advocating for you in order to help you
in your place of work and that's not
always women looking after other women
it's men as well and in terms of you
know men making it a comfortable
environment for women to have their say
and forge their career paths did you
have men helping you along the way in
terms of believing in you and backing
you absolutely there are I mean it's
three at least three I can think of that
gave me an opportunity you know I
remember conversation with one where I
was trying to convince him of a role
that I wanted to take that involved a
project and really I wasn't necessarily
qualified but
took a risk of me and he gave me the
opportunity I did say to him for it all
goes wrong you know you can throw me out
the door but he took a risk and he gave
me the opportunity and my career
flourished as a consequence of
delivering that so there are lots of
different men that have advocated for me
and there are lots of men in the city
there are male allies and male champions
you know you have the United Nations he
for she campaign so I think we also do
on on in my business on where the city
is we give men a voice through those
interviews because a lot of them are
championing gender but we don't often we
sometimes we just see the negative side
of it but from my perspective you need
both on the journey when you go into
schools when young girls talk to you
what do they want to be when they grow
up how do they talk to you about what
their career is going to look like do
you think it's changed from say 20 years
ago when we were at school and looking
at what we were gonna be doing most of
them don't see any barriers in terms of
what they can be you know that's what
I've noticed over the years and speaking
in schools for the last seven or eight
years there are a lot more bolder in
terms of and that's where we want them
to be there shouldn't be this kind of
barrier as in I can't do that because
it's men that's only ever existed in
those roles or you know I've never you
know I can never operate a crane or you
know be an engineer because absolutely
you can and if there's no one up there
that looks like you then be the pioneer
be the first is there a fast-forward
button we compress and when I say that I
think about things like quotas for women
on boards I think about positive
discrimination is that something you'd
back to get women to the next step that
bit quicker in terms of positive bias we
want to get there by our own merit
so I'd hate to think that I'd ever got a
job on the basis that I'm a woman
sometimes I've had recruiters ring me up
and be you know we are looking for this
particular position on this advisory
board and they specifically want a woman
and I think okay I can understand are
they're trying to gender balance yeah
but it really should be the best person
for the job and it's not just should be
about women it should be about different
diversity different voices in that room
you're almost building institutions and
society again from the bottom up because
it's all been built with men in mind so
without those quotas or positive bias
and we really willing to wait for a
generation if I roll back ten years ago
when I first started kind of getting
involved with the gender agenda there
was no there was no measurement there
was no women development just was not on
the on the cards there was no we need to
do more of this in schools or things
like that there was no focus so in ten
years time you know we've had things
like me to times up say government
legislation about reporting you know we
there have been things that have moved
us forward women on boards it's on the
agenda so at the moment or the moment
although it feels like all we're doing
is talking when you're looking to make
that big cultural shift and that big
societal change we're not going to get
there overnight
you do have days where you're like you
know why are we all kind of pushing ball
but we can't give up give up because as
a collective there's so many people
doing things around the progression of
women being work VH Human Rights you
know domestic violence that eventually
we can't give up on that because you
have small steps however small are
contributing towards a change what would
your message be to young women watching
now thinking about their futures I think
one of the messages I would give them is
the future is very much in your hands
even when you get to an employer a ploy
can map out you know different things
for you to do but you have to drive a
lot of that so if you're a youngster if
you can get add even a day's work
experience and if you don't necessarily
have access to those opportunities going
to go in the shops and see if you even
if you can just get one day at somewhere
to so that you see the landscape of work
that you could potentially do but there
underlying messages you can be whatever
you want to be you've just got a drive
back